allez on continue nos entretiens du
week-end avec cette fois Christine
sauvage bonjour votre librairie lettre
voisine installée à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux qui porte bien son
nom fait ce samedi c'est dix ans 10 ans
déjà j'ai envie de dire vous êtes
j'avais oui 10 ans oui
mais c'est un bon anniversaire
compliqué très enthousiasmant au niveau
des rencontres des conseils donnés aux
clients d'une clientèle qui de proximité
qui s'est habituée à nous et nous ne
sommes habitués à eux et puis qui qui a
pris le chemin de la librairie et qui
continue à venir peut-être ton corps de
plus en plus parce que parce qu'il y a
eu pendant un moment la vague des des
grandes surfaces culturelles et puis que
on revient un petit peu au commerce de
proximité etc pour le service le conseil
la convivialité aussi les gens se
rencontrent par l'entre eux se donnent
des conseils c'est c'est assez agréable
et vous dites pourtant c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué au niveau économique au
niveau économique c'est très compliqué
c'est très compliqué au niveau
commercial parce que les locaux
commerciaux sont très chers je ne vous
cacherai pas que les loyers vont
commerciaux sont très chers sur la vie
nouvelle pour pour un libraire comme
pour d'autres commerces et puis que
l'économie du livre est confrontée à des
tas de problèmes qui sont liés bon il y
a eu l'année dernière des changements de
TVA maintenant il y a la crise qui que
l'on ressent très très fortement et puis
ils sont très fortement ça les gens
hésitent à acheter peut-être des beaux
livres préfèrent des livres moins
coûteux ou bon on voit que le roman est
devenu le roman les aisselles les livres
autour de 20-25 euros si on veut sont
devenus vraiment les cadeaux de pour les
gens qui aiment les lire et que par
exemple pour les fêtes les beaux livres
ont été plus ou moins boudées c'est vrai
alors par contre il y a un renouveau
niveau
des albums jeunesse par exemple de la
littérature jeunesse qui qui a explosé
ces dernières années et on a de jeunes
lecteurs on a contrairement j'irai
l'état d'esprit oui oui
moi je suis pas pessimiste sur la
lecture parce que même s'il y a d'autres
médias aussi qui entre en jeu un bon
c'est sûr que internet grignote petit à
petit département
oui mais c'est vraiment à la marque pour
l'instant c'est la marge mais par contre
on a aussi bon moi je je suis assez
optimiste parce que
j'irai il y a des très bons lecteurs de
tous les âges de tous les âges et il y a
vraiment des passionnés lectures en tout
cas votre librairie elle fête ses 10 ans
elle sera samedi à partir de 11h vous
allez avoir des des auteurs des
illustrateurs des éditeurs qui vont se
bousculer dans la librairie auteur et
des amis lecteurs du coup vous êtes
venus aussi avec des coups de cœur oui
les coups de cœur de des auteurs qui
seront présents donc on va commencer par
anis Boutin cœur de hibou
bien connu Saint Michel
Raphaël etc et il reprend ses les
histoires et les contes au tout la
mythologie autour des anges voilà avec
de très belles illustrations aussi
originales voilà
capté la bonne lumière mais enfin il y a
un ange au milieu je pense qu'on vient
Marco c'est un illustrateur alors c'est
un illustrateur de BD qui travaille
aussi bien avec donc géo là chez Dargo
que avec bambou il a fait plusieurs
séries il travaille alors c'est un
masque qui nous vient vraiment du sud de
la France qui a fait avec géo trois BD
alors il est actuellement au lycée au
collège Champollion pour en parler avec
des élèves de 4e
spectateurs vont savoir tout Marco il
est alors Marco donc c'est appeler à
déchiffrer à raconter des histoires dans
des pays étrangers donc celui-ci les
enfants de l'ombre en Chine un autre se
passe au Mali le crochet annuaire la
conteuse des glaces se passe dans le
monde
et ce sont des très très beaux récits
donc ce qu'on appelle des one shot c'est
à dire un seul livre qui raconte toute
l'histoire et avec des dessins parfois
qui qu'on pourrait rapprocher de
l'arsenêtre qu'on pourrait rapprocher
d'autres dessinateurs mais qui qui sont
vraiment intéressants et qui l'on peut
donner mettre entre toutes les mains ça
c'est un avancé
son dernier donc vient d'être édité chez
bambou ça sera sans doute un triptyque
bon ces voyages en Chine que qui est
vraiment tout récent si on aime les
voyages donc Marco a découvert moi
j'adore quand vous venez parce que je
découpe plein de choses j'adore ça on va
finir avec ce gros gros livre magnifique
alors c'est c'est un petit bijoux voyage
parmi my curiosité merveilleuse c'est un
bijou aussi bien pour les adultes que
pour les enfants alors un insert a
toujours des idées assez géniales
découvre chaque pays avec ses
spécialités en dessin en images c'est à
dire que les enfants vont découvrir des
pays enfin le Groenland la Suède et à
chaque fois on aura les villes
principales l'activité principale les
animaux vraiment c'est une mine
extraordinaire au pif et chaque voilà
l'Islande avec des chevaux des poissons
bien sûr Islande les volcans et
à chaque fois c'est une découverte
incroyable et moi je pense que c'est un
livre qui est un livre familial donc il
a un petit côté comme un livre ancien
d'ailleurs qui plaît aux adultes mais
mais les enfants alors eux cherchent
tous les détails évidemment
pas bien le voir j'essaie de le montrer
mais voilà j'ai pas son poids bien parce
qu'il est extraordinaire voilà mais
c'est magnifique parce qu'il y a plein
plein de petits détails de petites
histoires de petits mots de petits
dessins c'est magnifique c'est un livre
que l'on prend que l'on pose que l'on
reprend et que l'on garde
enfin bon voilà
bien sûr bon c'est un ami donc il nous
suit depuis le début et il viendra
dédicacer aussi ses grands livres de
cuisine parce que c'est un gourmet qui a
écrit quatre très beaux livres de
cuisine et sur le chocolat les épices
les soupes les jardins du monde entier
et on va déguster aussi voilà donc si
vous êtes curieux si vous aimez la
littérature et donc si vous êtes
gourmand gourmands de livres et
gourmands tout court vous pouvez vous
rendre donc samedi à partir de 11h à la
librairie les lettres voisines avoisin
bretonnées librairie qui fête ses 10 ans
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur le
plateau du 7 8 allée puis pour être
complet aussi sur l'actualité des
librairies le pavé du Canada Montigny
accueille ce samedi aussi mais cette
fois à 15h l'écrivain et Frédéric
Tristan Frédéric Tristan qui avait reçu
le Grand Prix du
roman de la société des gens et des
Lettres en 1981 voir donc il sera samedi
25 mai à 15h à la librairie du pavé du
canal